hi my name is Megan hey Megan how are
you good how are you good but nervous um
oh don't be nervous we as you can tell
we're just uh we're just hanging out
we're fools hanging out we're idiots
well yeah kind of yeah um my questions
for whoever wants to answer but um when
you were a kid and somebody would ask
you what you wanted to be when you grew
up what would you say oh podcast
sidekick
you were in the
sandbox you made yourself a third chair
yeah had a sand nailed it little pine
cone for a microphone spoke once every
minutes you're I have to say on these
ones you're a little quieter when we're
in the studio you are a you are a a your
lips are a fla I know I need to walk
that back and well I just think you know
I'm just getting too big for my britches
you know oh no I think you're just
getting if you're saying that phrase
you're just getting too
old what about you son what did you want
to be I know this might be shocking I
didn't have very many
Ambitions you were blazing up at four
years old right I honestly like looking
back on I don't think I was ever like oh
I can't wait to be a doctor um thank God
I
well Sona you lost another one what are
you going to do he had a full life he
was
26 he came in for a hernia operation you
killed him
well who's up for some
Margies Mar posttop
Margies um no I don't I really didn't
have any like I know it's sad but I was
just kind of like that sounds cool I'll
try that I know I wanted to work in TV
that that's the only thing I really
loved so I knew that but I didn't know
what right so I did it yeah I
um check yeah did do
it I wanted to when I was a kid I really
did want to be an Entertainer and I
thought and but and I've said this
before but back then um pre- streaming
and just three television stations and
not great reception you just watched
what was on and mostly what was on
channel 38 or Channel 56 were old movies
cuz that's what they ran cuz they didn't
have enough content and so I grew up
watching old movies and old musicals and
I thought that's what entertainment was
so in like the 19 late 1970s I was
thinking I need to know how to tap
dance I need to learn how to talk real
fast in an oldtime voice you know I need
to get like one of those straw hats and
say Hey you let's get over here there's
a fire at mcc's Barn let's go you know
and then like
up I better know a few Tunes you know
and uh button up your over coat when the
wind blows free take care of yourself
you belong to me OD oio and then I'd go
to school and do this and the
beatings would
commence here's this kid with a bll
haircut hey everybody my name's Conan
that's a cool name ladies line up and
I'll have kiss you later but up your
over kiss you then all these kids you
know from Somerville and stuff would
just be oh I'll beat him first you beat
him second they had me I didn't know I
wanted to be a bully when I grew up till
I saw this guy they had conversation he
inspired me to be a bu yeah they were
very organized bullies here's how we're
going to do
it Jason you're first Christy you're
second yeah exactly I'll hit him
primarily in the throat soft
tissue bullies having a convers bullies
really organized bullies they have a
flowchart how it's going to work they
prepared visual yeah everybody look at
your hand
out and I'm in the corner fellas hurry
it
up you're just standing there I've got
tap dancing lessons to get
to these toes are ready to
twinkle